WE'RE GONNA GET A COUPLE MINUTES
JUST TO WE GET A MEMBER OF
THE -- ALL THE PARTY
TO COME IN AND AT THAT POINT
I'LL START WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE
A GOOD AFTERNOON WE WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS
AND CONVEYANCE -- NOTICING
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOW START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE -- MEN AND
AND -- I ALSO WANT TO ANNOUNCE
THAT MISTER OBERNOLTE IS NOT
-- PRESENT TODAY -- -- THERE'S
A PRESSING ISSUE THIS DISTRICT
WHICH SHE IS ATTENDING ON MR
TENDS BEEN APPOINTED AS THE
COMMITTEES -- VICE CHAIR FOR
TODAY -- ALSO MR PATERSON WILL
BE PRESENTING SB SIX OH THREE
ON BEHALF OF CENTER VARGAS TODAY
CORRECTION -- MR TRANSIT
POINTED IT AS A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE NOT THE BY
STRIPE I APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU NUMBER
MISTER BRADFORD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT --
YEAH WE WERE BORN READY
FOR YOU MISTER RIGHT --
THESE -- TEARS GREAT
QUESTION WHAT COULD
WE GET YOUR BOOSTER SEAT TOO IF
YOU'D LIKE THAT'S WHAT I NEED
REAL -- ANY PARTICULAR PROCEDURE
I YOUR PREFERENCE I WILL START
WITH -- LOOKED FOR VIÇT GREATER
INTEGRATION A SB SIX SEVEN SIX
-- THANK YOU FOR AS WE START
THIS BIG MEASURE DEALS WITH --
ELECTRICAL GREAT -- CHARGING
AND AS WE LOOK AT TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE YOU VIS AT PEAK CHARGING
-- WILL DEMAND EQUIVALENT TO AN
ENTIRE POWER PLANT -- THE
CITY'S BEEN SCRATCHED INGRID
INTEGRATION FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND WE'RE NOW TRYING
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM -- WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS AT
PEAK LOAD IF EVERYONE STARTS
TO CHARGER CARS INTO ELECTRICAL
VEHICLES TAKE OFF AS WE ALL
HOPE THEY WILL IT WILL HAVE
A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON OUR
GREAT -- HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
DAVID AND -- LESSON GUITAR
SLUSH WORK SO DAVID
PLEASE A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR SANTIAGO -- IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
TO CENTER BRADFORD FOR HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC AS THE SENATOR SAID
MY NAME IS DAVID SCHLOSSBERG I
REPRESENT A MOTOR WORKS WHERE
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION MANUFACTURE AS WELL AS
AN ENERGY SERVICES PROVIDER --
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVEN SIX
WHICH WOULD CREATE A MARKET
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE
FOR VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRATION
SERVICES AND IN OUR STATE
AND GIVEN THAT MANY AMBITIOUS
POLICIES WE'VE ADOPTED TO
RAPIDLY DE CARBONIZED ARE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR VEHICLE
RID INTEGRATION IS ESSENTIAL
TO ENSURING THAT ARE LARGE
INVESTMENT IN TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION -- IS DONE IN
A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES BENEFITS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS -- BOTH
EASY OWNERS AND -- THOSE NOT YET
ADOPTING BY ENSURING THAT THIS
INCREASE IN EVEY DEMAND IS USED
AS A WEEK LEASE COST RESOURCE
TO INTEGRATE CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS RENEWABLE ENERGY
TARGETS SO THIS BILL IS TIMELY
AN ESSENTIAL GIVEN THE IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT THE
STATE IS COMMITTED TO THE A
COLLECTOR VACATION AND CHARGING
STATION DEPLOYMENT AS WELL AS
THE TRANSMIT TRANSITION WE'LL
SEE AN EASY MARKET OVER THE
NEXT DECADE AS WE MOVE FROM
THESE EARLY ADOPTERS TO THE MASS
MARKET WITH EDIE'S ACCESSIBLE
FOR ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU
-- ANY ADDITIONAL --
SUPPORT WHAT IS THIS
TIFFANY VAN TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
ANOTHER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
HUNDRED NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT
PROSECUTORS HERE ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCE ENERGY
ECONOMY IN SUPPORT
GARCIA THE ALLEGED VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
TELL TRÊN ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CONSERVATION
VOTERS AN ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY
MAIN OPPOSITION -- WITNESSES
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND --
I THANK YOU MISTER I AGAIN THIS
IS A JUST A ST FORT MEASURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
RELIABLE SYSTEM AS -- ELECTRICAL
VEHICLES GROW WE ARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE GRID IS A RELIABLE
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
SHIPPING COSTS TO THOSE --
RESIDENTS TO I WILL NEVER
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS THIS IS
GOING TO BE A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS -- THAT WE MAKE AND
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS IS
A COMMON SENSE MEASURES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A RELIABLE
-- GRID AND THE RATE TO FAIR
OUT FOR THOSE WHO USE IT AND
-- FOR THOSE WHO DON'T AND FOR
THAT MEASURE -- MATTER I ASKED
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
BRADFORD THE BILL ENJOYS DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS AND
WHEN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM --
HOLLANDER ENTERTAIN A FIRST
AND A SECOND AT THAT TIME THE
PROJECT OF CEDAR SECOND THANK
YOU -- NEXT BILL THANK YOU
OUR NEXT BILLS A SEVEN OH
FOR ITS -- IMPROVING LIFELINE
ACCESS -- SEVEN FOUR MAKES A
NUMBER IMPROVEMENTS THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM THAT WILL INCREASE
PARTICIPATION AMONG ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO I DID A BILL WHILE IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO ADDRESS LIFELINE
IN EXPANDING UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE MAJORITY OF CUSTOMERS NO
LONGER HAD A LAND LINE THEY WERE
MOVING TO A WIRELESS DEVICE OR
AVOID -- INTERNET TECHNOLOGY
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE LAND LINE
HOW ALSO AB OPPORTUNITY TO
USE BE A LIFELINE FOR TO SPENT
IN THIS WIRELESS WORLD THAT WE
LIVE IN MOST IMPORTANTLY OUT
WITH LARA UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
TO PARTICIPATION SPECIALLY FOR
FOR AFFORDABLE COMMUNITY GROUPS
LIKE FOSTER YOUTH VETERANS
INFORMALLY INCARCERATED WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS PRODUCT SB SEVEN
FOUR WILL ALSO EVALUATE WHETHER
BROADBAND SHOULD BE INCLUDED AND
LIFELINE AS A WAY TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AGAIN AS A -- A
MEASURE THAT WE DID A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT
WAS TAKEN OVER BY THE P. YOU SEE
AND WE KNOW THE SUCCESS THAT
THEY DID NOT HAVE IN ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE SO -- LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE RECOMMENDED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT SOME TYPE
OF CHANGE A LIFE LINE NOW AND
ALSO ALLOW FOR MORE ANALYSIS
ON THIS ISSUE -- THIS BILL
DOES EXACTLY THAT -- EVERYONE
AGREES TO PROGRAM DESERVES
IMPROVEMENT IN S. BEFORE AT
SEVEN OH FOUR IS IT STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION I RESPECT LAST RIVAL
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ANY MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YES --
JUST A BIG EXPLAIN I SUPPORT
THIS BUT IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN
AS FAR AS THE EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THE ENROLLMENT
FOR THE -- CONSTITUENTS
THAT ARE SPECIFIED LIKE YOU
SAID FOSTER AND OTHERS --
AS THE THE RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED IT THE P. YOU SEE
IS HOLDING THOSE RESOURCES
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THE ENROLLMENT IS NOT ROBUST
AND WHAT TYPE OF RESOURCES
ARE SITTING THERE AS FAR AS
IF YOU KNOW AND WHAT ARE SOME
IDEAS THAT THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
DOING -- I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
THOSE RESOURCES WITH SOME
IDEAS WERE LOOKING AT IS USING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
AGAIN THE P. YOU SEE THROUGH
THEIR ATTEMPTS FIVE YEARS AGO
USE STREET TEAMS AND AS WE'VE
ALL SEEN FOLKS WITH THE POP UPS
IN ON THE CORNERS IN FRONT OF
OUR COUNTY BUILDINGS IN THAT WAS
NOT EFFECTIVE WAY OF CAPTURING
THIS MARKET SO WE'RE GOING TO
-- CAPTURE DATA WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO NOW WITH THESE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING WITH -- SOME THE ARE
COUNTY AGENCIES AT WAR IN TOUCH
WITH THESE EMANCIPATED FOSTER
YOUTH AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS SO THE DATA IS THERE
JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT
TO THOSE ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
A LOT MORE EFFECTIVE SO THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE
IS MAKE SURE THAT WE REACH THE
CUSTOMER BASE TO REALLY NEEDS
IT L. ALSO LOOK AT THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY A LIFELONG CUSTOMER
THAT I HAVE MIGRATED AWAY FROM
LAND LINE IN REACHING OUT TO
THEM DIRECTLY TOO BUT THE STREET
TEAM APPROACH WE ALL AGREE DID
NOT WORK AND IS NOT WORKING
THANK YOU IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ALSO THIS BILL
DOES ENJOYED YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN WE SET A
QUORUM -- ALERTING THE FIRST
IN A SECOND -- CLAIMS RECORD
THANK YOU COMMEMORATIVE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
MR PATERSON WILL
PRESENT SB SIX OH THREE
MISTER PATTON YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
MEMBERS UP HERE TO PRESENT
THE SB SIX OH THREE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BOARD JUST HE HAS ASKED
ME TO CONVEY HIS ACCEPTANCE
OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THAT SB SIX OH THREE
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO PERFORM
ONE OF ITS CORE FUNCTIONS
RATE REGULATION INEFFICIENT
MANNER FOR TEN VERY SMALL RURAL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES RANGING
IN SIZE FROM LESS THAN THREE
HOW TO CUSTOMERS TO JUST OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND CUSTOMERS FOR
DECADES THE COMMISSION HANDLED
THE RAPE CASES OF THE SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES THROUGH THE
LESS BURDENSOME ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS TYPICALLY TAKING LESS
THAN A YEAR FROM START TO FINISH
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE PC STARTED
REQUIRING A SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES TO GO THROUGH THE
FORMAL APPLICATION PROCESS WHICH
IS THE TRIAL LIKE ADVERSARIAL
PROCESS USUALLY RESERVED FOR
COMPLEX RATE CASES OF THE LARGE
UTILITIES THE FORMAL PROCESS
REQUIRED REQUIRES THE USE OF
ATTORNEYS AND ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE IT HAS BECOME BURDENSOME
TIME CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED IS IT
WAY OUT OF PROPORTION TO THE
SIZE OF THE SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE
THE COMMISSION'S USE OF THE
FORMAL PROCESS HAS RESULTED
IN MANY OF THESE RAPE CASES
TAKING FIFTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO COMPLETE INSTEAD OF
THE TRADITIONAL ONE YEAR SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION'S FORTY
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES ARE
STRETCHED TOO THIN OVER NUMEROUS
PROCEEDINGS ACROSS ALL UTILITY
SECTORS SB SIX OH THREE IT
RESTORES THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE ADVICE LETTER PROCESS FOR
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANY RATE
CASES THAT CREATES A REASONABLE
STANDARD FOR WHEN THE COMMISSION
CAN REJECT AND ADVICE LETTER
AND REQUIRE A SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANY TO FILE A FORMAL
APPLICATION HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
YOUR LAND BENSON OF A CAL CALM
AND A PAN LOOMIS OF C. I. T. C.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I WANT TO THINK
-- CERTAINLY SENATOR BOARD
JUST FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
AND AND ESPECIALLY SUPPLEMENT
JIM PATTERSON HE'S VERY
FAMILIAR WITH OUR ISSUES AND
WE APPRECIATE HIM PRESENTING
THE BILL TODAY WANT TO EXTEND
A VERY BIG THANK YOU TO
YOUR STAFF ADMIN -- AS THE
CONSULTANT WHO HAS JUST DONE
JUST FABULOUS WORK IN WORKING
WITH US IN WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS INTERESTED IN
THE SPELL -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
-- THE BILL AS EXPLAINED BY SEN
A SOME SENATORS CAN GIVE YOU A
A NEW PROMOTION ASSEMBLYMAN
PATTERSON IS LITERALLY JUST
AN ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGE THAT
JUST CODIFIES WHAT THE PC
HAS DONE FOR OVER TWO DECADES
THEY'VE ALWAYS ALLOWED THE
ADVICE LETTER PROCESS TO HAPPEN
ARBITRARILY THEY HAVE DECIDED
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF TO
TO MAKE OUR SMALL COMPANIES GO
THROUGH A FORMAL RIGHT PROCESS
THE ABILITY TO FILE A RATE --
DID VICE LETTER IS IMPORTANT
TO US FOR COST BURDEN AS
WELL AS JUST BURDENS SOME OF
THE FORMAL PROCESS BECAUSE
HE'S SUCH A BURDEN ON OUR SMALL
COMPANIES -- THE THE COST IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL AT TIMES WITH THE
FORMAL RATE CASE PROCESS PLUS
IT'S IT THE THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THE SAME
INFORMATION PROVIDED FOR AN
ADVICE LETTER PROCESS IS THE
SAME INFORMATION PROVIDED
THROUGH A FORMAL RATE CASE THAT
PROCESS SO THE INFORMATION IS
THE SAME OUR COMPANIES OPEN
UP THEIR BOOKS THEY ALLOW
THE P. YOU SEE TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS REQUEST DATA AND IT
ALLOWS FOR OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO ALSO PARTICIPATE IN IN
IN THE ADVICE LETTER PROCESS
-- THAT'S I DON'T WANT TO
SAY TOO MUCH MORE OTHER THAN
THIS IS REALLY JUST CAUGHT
A FINE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE THAT'S BEEN AT THE
PC FOR YEARS THANK YOU SO MUCH
ENTER UP JUST FOR ONE SECOND
SO I CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM
IN THE WILL PROCEED -- MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SANTIAGO BUT A WHOLE THAT
BONTA BRO CERVANTES
CHEN EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE
LOW PATTERSON AIR
CORPS OVER RODRIGUEZ
WE HAVE A FIRST AND AND A SECOND
-- BUT I WANT TO PROCEED A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PAM LIMITS AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES WHICH IS THE COALITION
FOR LOBBYING SERVICES AND
WHERE YEAH FOR A COALITION FOR
LOBBYING PURPOSES AND -- WE
ARE IN WHOLE HEARTED SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE --
THAT THIS COMMITTEE -- SUPPORTS
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESS SEES
THAT THE COMMISSION AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
US SUPPORT WITNESSES
ANY MAN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HI TERRY DISSENTERS REPRESENTING
THE -- PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
WE WERE -- FORMALLY OPPOSE BUT
WITH THE BILL AS AMENDED NOW WE
ARE OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
-- OPPOSITION WITNESSES ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE HAVE PEPPERS AS I CAN --
BEFORE I WHICH FOR WE DO THE
CLOTHES I DO WANT TO THANK
-- -- THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL FOR WORKING REALLY REALLY
HARD WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
ON THIS AND IT WASN'T EASY
I KNOW THAT BUT BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTH IT AND YOU GOT A
GOOD BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND TIME AND --
BEGINS TO CONSULT HARD WORK
ON THIS -- INCLUDES STATEMENTS
QUICKLY OUT SIX OH THREE WILL
SAVE THE PC AND THE SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES TIME ENERGY
AND MONEY DURING THE RATE
CASE PROCESS WHICH IS GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ASK FOR
YOUR HIGH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WILL FIRST THE
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BUSH'S DUPONT'S AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO I BURN A HOLE THAT
BUT A WHOLE VAT I BONTA BRO
BRO ON ICE ADVANTIS CHAN
CHAN I EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
I LOW PATTERSON AYE PATTERSON
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
SIGH MY TAKE A MOMENT
TO SINCE THERE'S NO AUTHORS
TO GO BACK THE SP SIX
SEVEN SIX AND WE WE NEED A
FIRST AND THIS AND SECOND
OF THIS MEASURES AS WELL THANKS
WITH SO MANY RIGHT NOW
SEE GUYS CAN GET OUT HERE
SOON AS EVERYBODY ELSE
WE NEED A FIRST AND A SECOND
ON SB -- SIX SEVEN SIX AND
DOES A DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
WE HAVE A FIRST AND WE
HAVE A SECOND -- MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS TO PASTA APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
BUT THE WHOLE THAT BUT A
WHOLE THAT I BONTA BRO
BROUGH ON ICE CERVANTES
CHAN CHAN I EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW PATTERSON
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIGH
EIGHT ZERO MISSION ITSELF EIGHT
ZERO MEASURES OUT I'LL DO THE
SAME WITH SB SEVEN OH FOR IT WE
WOULD NEED A FIRST AND A SECOND
WELL FIRST WE HAVE A SECOND --
MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO POST TO
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO ONLINE BUT A WHOLE THAT
WHOLE VÀ I BONTA BRO
BRUNO CERVANTES CHEN
CHEN NOT VOTE IN EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW
PATTERSON ARSENAL VOTE IN
COOK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIGNED
A FIVE TO ONE MEASURES
ON CALL WE'RE NOW WAITING
FOR HER ONE AUTHOR
AND WE WAIT NO LONGER
I MEMBERS I'M HERE
PERCENT SB FIFTY NINE --
THIS HAS TO DO IT TRYING
TO GET OUR HEADS AROUND THE
GREAT CHALLENGES AND ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES EXISTING WITH
REGARDS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES IN OUR CITIES MAKE
SURE WE HAVE BETTER PLANNING
IN PLACE MAKE SURE ACTUALLY
TAKING A A PROACTIVE FORCEFUL
LOOK AT AT AT WHAT THIS MIGHT
MEAN HOW WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME POTENTIAL INCREDIBLE
BENEFITS IN TERMS OF CONGESTION
REDUCTION IN EFFICIENCIES BUT
ALSO SOME STUDIES SUGGESTED THAT
IF NOT DONE RIGHT AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES COULD ACTUALLY
HELP TO EXACERBATE SOME OF
OUR CHALLENGES THERE WAS A
STUDY DONE WITH SEVERAL ARE
UNIVERSITIES WHERE THEY GAVE
FAMILIES -- KIND OF A YOU KNOW
A FREE SHOW FOR BASICALLY KIND
OF RECREATING WHAT WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A DRIVERLESS
VEHICLES ACTUALLY TURNED OUT
THAT FAMILIES ENDED UP BEING A
LOT MORE TIME DRIVING AROUND AND
THEY WOULD OFTENTIMES HAVE THE
CAR CIRCLE THE BLOCK -- SO
THEY BE READY TO PICK THEM UP
AS OPPOSED TO GO ON PARKING
SO ACTUALLY INCREASE OF OUR
CONGESTION CHALLENGES IF WE'RE
NOT REALLY CAREFUL SO YOU KNOW
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY THAT TIME
FEEL CLOSE COULD REALLY HELP TO
REVOLUTIONIZE TRANSPORTATION WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S DONE IN
A GOOD WAY THAT IT'S MERRY TO
OUR OUR BROADER PLANNING GOALS
AND -- AND WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO WORK WITH -- WITH EVERYBODY
WITH ALL THE OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN DROPPED WE WORKED REALLY
HARD FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE -- HAPPY TO THAT
HI TO CONTINUE THAT PROCESS BUT
BUT BUT ACTUALLY APPRECIATED
AND WE HAVE AND WE RE GUESS
HERE FROM THE NEW CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS AND ARE VEGAS FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES MAY BE
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT INNOVATION
AND TRANSPORTATION SAYS
AUTOMOBILES ARE FIRST INVENTED
THOUGH STILL IN THEIR INFANCY
AUTONOMOUS CARS AND TRUCKS
TO RADICALLY TRANSFORM HOW
PEOPLE IN GOOD TO HAVE AROUND
WITH PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS
GOOD OR BAD FOR SAFETY EQUITY
AND ENVIRONMENT IT'S TIME FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
THE SAAS OPPORTUNITIES AND
RECESS TECHNOLOGY PRESENTS AND
DETERMINE THE FORWARD LOOKING
POLICIES THAT WILL BE NEEDED
TO STEER AT TIMES VEHICLES
IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION AT
UNION A CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
WE ARE PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND ARE LOOKING UP THE RULES
ECONOMIST VEHICLES WILL PLAY
AS OF MANY ASPECTS OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY WE SEE BOTH WRISTS
NOT PERTINENTES WE ARE GLAD
THE BILL RETAINS KEEP FOCUS
ON ISSUES OF POLLUTION AND
CONGESTION THERE SUB GROUP
DEVOTED TO REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BUILDING HEALTHY
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
FACE REASONS WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT SB FIFTY NINE TODAY
SECOND WE ARE FIRST WE
HAVE A SECOND TO HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES RESEARCHERS
HERE ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY IN SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING SIR AND TELL
WITH THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT PRECIADO AUTHOR
INCLUDING US IN THE ESTATE
CALLED THE WORKGROUP THANK YOU
BUT MANY RC
WITH CAL SORRY WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS BILL WE THINK
THAT IT WITHIN TWO HUNDRED YEARS
AGO WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT YOU
KNOW AND THAT DIESEL ENGINES WE
PROBABLY TO PLAN A LITTLE BETTER
AS WE APPRECIATE THIS BILL
KAREN SHOCK FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
CAL WE'D WITH THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN SUPPORT
KAREN PERKINS THREE FIFTY
ANY MAN MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ADDITIONAL POSITION WITNESSES
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE
HAVE A FIRST OR SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PROFESSOR MINERVA
THANK YOU -- MEN'S ACTIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FORCES TO PASTA
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO ONLINE BURN A HOLE THAT
BEEN A WHOLE THAT HIGH BONTA
BRO BROWN ALTHOUGH TEN
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGH
CHEN CAN I ADD ONE OF
GARCIA HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMALA DOVE ON A LOW LOW
AYE PATTERSON PATTERSON
NO COOKS OVER SILVA AYE
RODRIGUEZ BUT WITH THIS
SITE BONTA BONTA ONLINE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MEMBERS
THE GERMANS NINE TWO
I NINETY ONE MEASURES OUT
NOW WILL GO BACK AND
WE'VE GOT ONE BILL ON CALL SO
LET'S GO TO SB SEVEN OH FOUR
I HAVE A NUMBER FOR SB
SEVEN A FULL MOTIONS
TO PASTA APPROPRIATIONS
BONTA I
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGN
HAD WATER GARCIA HOLDEN
LOW LOW I
ONE MEASURES EIGHTY
ONE MEASURES OUT
IN THE INTEREST OF GETTING
MEMBERS SCHEDULES MOVING LET
ME RUN THROUGH ALL THESE REALLY
QUICKLY SONY START OFF
THE FIRST -- FIRST PAULA ONGOING
FOLLOWER -- SB FIFTY NINE
WOULD YOU NOT ONS
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SIX OH THREE
BONTA BONTA I
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGN
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
LOW LOW I
ELEVEN TWO ZERO MEASURE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB SIX SEVEN SIX
BONTA BONTA I CERVANTES
SEVEN TO SIGN EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN LOW LOW
I ELEVEN TWO ZERO
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN OH FOUR
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
EVERYONE'S HERE
YEAH
THE FIRST
RIGHT YEAH YEAH
--
YEAH YEAH
YEAH YEAH THIS IS A
RESULT IN THAT IT HAPPENS
I I BELIEVE
YEAH YEAH
I WAS LIKE YEAH
THIS WILL GIVE THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT THREE MORE MINUTES
US THE NUMBERS GET OUT ON
OKAY WILL HAVE IF
YOU HAVE A BUSTLING
THE THE CARE IS
AVAILABLE FOR
THE CASHIER SAYS
HI THIS IS JOE
SO SORT OF A FEW
YOUR AVAILABLE THIS
OKAY
THIS SITUATION
WE CAN BEGIN
MENTAL ONE
I NUMBER ONE SB FIFTY
NINE PURPOSES OF ADD ON
HOLDEN HI EDUARDO GARCIA
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SIX OH THREE
MOTION WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
SIX SEVEN SIX MOTION IS TO
PASTA APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MEASURE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
SEVEN OH FULL MOTIONS TO PASTA
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN HOLDEN I MEASURE
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
YEAH
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANKS